notre expert en relations
internationales c'est lady tôt ce matin
de claude blanche maisons closes
blanchemaison heureux de vous retrouver
dans la matinale de rtl france alors
quels objectifs diplomate la diplomatie
turque poursuit-elle avec ses dialogues
avec athènes et ankara
en effet le discours de président recep
erdogan est soumise affaires étrangères
ont changé ce qui marque sans doute
aussi un changement de stratégie
il n'ya plus d'accusations vis-à-vis de
l'europe qui ne tiendrait pas ses
engagements vis à vis de la turquie
l'accusation vis-à-vis de la france
présenté comme un pays hostile à l'islam
en général à la turquie en particulier
il y a une chance il de charme de
monsieur recep erdogan et le son
ministre des affaires étrangères qui lui
même a été envoyée les affaires
étrangères à bruxelles
à la fin de la semaine dernière pour
développer cette offensive de charme et
puis la réouverture de négociations avec
la grèce qui ont été suspendues pendant
cinq années
pourquoi cette nouvelle stratégie
premièrement parce que monsieur erdogan
se sont un peu isolé sur la scène
internationale après ses aventures
militaires en syrie après c'est
l'intervention en libye après aussi
c'est diverses activités en grand
méditerranée orientale et que
probablement il se rend compte que la
population
finalement ne réagit pas que voudrait
que comme il l'aurait souhaité sur la
fibre sur mûrement nationaliste qu'elle
considère que toutes ces opérations sont
coûteuses que la situation économique en
turquie est mauvaise et gueule
d'ailleurs le maire le nouveau maire
d'istanbul est devenu très populaire et
qu'ils risquent de causer des déboires à
monsieur erdogan lors des prochaines
élections donc change grand tarbes
changement de cap assez complet du côté
de monsieur erdogan vis-à-vis de la
grèce vis-à-vis de la france et les avis
de l'union européenne un changement de 4
merci pour le jeu de mots recep tayyip
erdogan a t-il une chance en tout cas
d'aboutir dans ses négociations avec
athènes claude avec athènes ça va être
compliqué parce que les différences de
points de vue sont tout à fait
différentes
athènes veut d'abord discuter de la
délimitation de la zone économique
exclusive autour de chesil or vous savez
que certains des îles en mer egée sont
très proches de la côte turque et de ce
point de vue la nature qui n'accepte pas
l'application pure et simple du droit de
la mer qui en effet impliquerait que ce
qui commande c'est l'extension du
plateau territoriale et avec ces villes
proches de la culture et la grèce prend
la part du lion en mer d'egée donc elle
a une différence de poids devenu majeur
est sans doute la raison pour laquelle
la turquie voulait aussi discuté dans
ces conversations de la délimitation des
zones excuses des zones économiques
exclusives partout entre la grèce et la
turquie
et pas seulement en mer egée ainsi
d'ailleurs que du contrôle des zones
aériennes et là on bute sur un élément
majeur c'est que la turquie soutient la
l'auto proclamée république du nord de
chypre et la principale vertu aux yeux
de la turquie de cette création turque
est en réalité de lui donner une zone de
maritimes supplémentaires pour ces
recherches gazier
or là il ya évidemment une difficulté
majeure puisque personne aucun pays à
part la turquie ne reconnaît cette
république du nord de chypre
il ya donc une difficulté importante
mais l'essentiel c'est que les
discussions et reprise entre la grèce et
la turquie est que ces discussions se
poursuivent pour en effet éviter la
reprise des affrontements qui pourraient
devenir des affrontements militaires
alors par ailleurs monsieur déroule la
misère affaires étrangères a passé deux
jours à bruxelles pour essayer de
convaincre l'union européenne que la
turquie voulait serait ancré en europe
vous les réouvrir les négociations
d'adhésion
hélas là aussi je crois que il a peu de
chance de se faire entendre
il nous reste un petit peu de temps
claude comment interprétez vous le fait
que la grèce ait racheté des yeux rafale
à la france dans ce contexte
bon c'est une se résulte en effet delà
de la période de crise
entre deux crises aiguës avec la turquie
et la grèce souhaitait de toute manière
on ouvrait une partie de ses avions de
combat
la france pouvait lui offrir dix huit
rafale dont certains sont un fait dont
certains sont d'occasion
pourquoi ce mélange est bien parce que
j'ai d'avions d'occasion sont moins
chers et surtout sans doute dans le cas
de la grèce parce qu'il peut être livrer
très rapidement
c'est à dire tout de suite donc la grèce
a choisi ses avions de combat rafale qui
en effet ont montré en opération leur
efficacité et notamment dans toutes les
opérations qui sont menées par la france
en zone sahélienne
donc il est assez logique que la grèce
ait fait ce choix plutôt que l'acheter
c'est dans les rayons ailleurs par
exemple aux états unis comme elle l'a
fréquemment fait l'an passé parce que
elle craignait peut-être que les
conditions soit attaché coopérant talion
votre pays la mairie ces conditions il
n'ya pas de condition particulière
puisque la france a promis son soutien
dans cette affaire merci beaucoup
claude blanchou maison pour votre
expertise le rappelle vous êtes notre
expert international